when you create a task caps algorithms
compare your task to millions of data
points to ensure our digital delivery is
accurate and timely but cap is still
learning so each task you create helps
make caps smarter let's see how easy it
is to create a task start on the task
screen you can find it by doing a left
swipe and clicking on tasks in the
drawer or you may already be on this
screen from your previous task to create
a task tap the big green plus button on
the upper right of the screen on the
describe your task screen tell cap what
you want to do I want to add today's low
and high temperature to a spreadsheet I
type add the low and high daily
temperatures to my spreadsheet hit the
green arrow you are now on an edit
screen cap may or may not have correctly
interpreted your task tap your finger
over step one and the recommended steps
to our slides in from the right the
correct source is today's weather report
in the weather domain
at the time of day you want to check the
data input the location for weather data
and be specific
step to check to see cap got this
correct if not again tap the step and
the recommended steps slide in from the
right scroll to onedrive for business
and select add line item to spreadsheet
under file name create the spreadsheet
name and include the extension xls or
xlsx if this spreadsheet didn't
previously exist kept will create it for
you
then provide a folder name this folder
should already exist finally provide a
worksheet named new line first you want
to select ingredients for your selected
domain use the ingredients icon to see
your options scroll to templo and select
now in order to have this in a separate
cell from other selected data you must
delineate it with the bar then go back
to ingredients and select temp high
close with a second bar hit save in the
upper right and you're done
give this task enough time to execute
depending on the time of day you
selected to read the low & high
temperatures from the weather report
then check onedrive for business pending
sync frequency and you will find the
data in your spreadsheet as specified
you may need to format the spreadsheet
columns for the numeric or other data
type you're saving to it